um you don't go inside a fight trying to
fight Muhammad Ali but I'll boxing them
pause
yes I'll have to be you coming for solve
get him
at no point in time am I gonna stand
there for you pencil pushing yellow
belly fat [__] I keep running for the
hell yeah
three times something goes wrong you
call for Phil Dominus Maximus Aurelius
jump he is the only one taking these
hard hidden questions be outside
you just saw Anakin turn into Darth
Vader they make it a good boy go evil
he said how am I he I'm grumpy
I'm I do apologize for being Snappy with
you
Ain't No More Mr Niceville oh that's it
what are we doing I'll keep acting like
this ain't the dude that brought us back